you know you said you had a really tough
audition process during when you did
pretty woman
well it wasn't tough it just i had one
uh audition
meeting with gary marshall
and uh he he
he said it's good dude you could do it
it's good it's it's good do you think
which is good feedback but great
there was no way he wanted me for this
part
he
i was not what he had in his head he
thought i was too young
uh too baby-faced and
uh too small um
i he knew that there was this physical
confrontation with richard gere's role
and uh i think the line that the casting
editor tommy is gary
felt like it would look like richard was
beating up a dwarf and since uh
disney was disney's producing this film
and you know they're protective of
dwarves so
gary i was a non-starter for gary and
without naming the actor he wanted
because that wouldn't be fair
but he knew who he wanted and they
couldn't make a deal with that actor the
guy just wouldn't do it for the money he
wasn't interested
and now the movie was shooting and that
role has to start and they don't have
anybody
and the casting director a woman named
diane crittenden
loved me for this role she just
she kept bringing me up and gary would
get
angry and angrier to the point where he
said if you if you say his name again
i'm gonna fire you
you know
and i think it was like
days before this character had to start
and she
she
somehow got richard gere to agree
to have me go to his office and she was
she brought a video camera
and our height difference you know was
not it was not nothing
so she they put phone books on the floor
and i stood on the phone books to sort
of approximate richard's height a little
more and we played one scene
that she shot and then richard
took that tape to gary threw it on his
destiny this is the guy
and it was under those circumstances
that i
walked into pretty woman with a director
that was not crazy to have me there but
then at the end of our first day
he he went i was wrong
it's the best we could have so he
he did a complete 180 so richard gere
stuck up for you and fought for you
he did
he did richard
i i mean because of diane crittenden and
richard gere
that movie happened for me without
both of them it would not have happened
and how did you how long did you have to
prepare for that role
uh a day
i mean
we made that we made that tape on a
wednesday or thursday
uh and i had to
uh
i think i started shooting on monday or
tuesday
and how pumped were you you're doing a
movie with richard gere was this like
this is one of the biggest things you
you're doing right now yeah oh of course
first of all it's it's a movie i mean
it's like a movie but it was not like
this was a this was a movie
and
i think i would have been on cloud nine
except a it was happening so fast and b
i was really i knew
this director doesn't he's not behind me
he's not happy i'm here
and pretty woman was a movie richard
when i got in the makeup trailer on the
first day richard had been shooting for
a couple weeks
and he said uh
get ready because i don't know what
movie we're making here
i i said what do you mean
he said you'll see you'll see
so i mean it's a famous story now but
pretty woman them on paper was
was a much more serious film uh they
didn't end up together at the end the
depiction of life as a street prostitute
was a little more
realistic
it didn't have a lot of its charms
and gary was
in some ways manufacturing this movie
out of his head so you'd get on the set
and thinking you were going to do one
thing and you'd wind up doing something
completely different so my
first day i walk onto the set and it's a
short scene
about the business machinations between
our two characters
and
you know i had a couple of things i said
well my character must be very
differential to this rich powerful boss
he's going to be
i had some ideas not many but
and richard had on a very fancy pair of
shoes that day they were just gorgeous
but they were like striking for a men's
shoe it was a very striking shoe and
gary noticed it and so when we came over
to rehearse we started running the
dialogue and gary on blade wait
when richard comes in talk about his
shoes
oh
all right okay
so
i started
busting richard's chops about hey pretty
fancy look at you tinkerbell where are
you you know so we're playing and gary's
laughing
he go let's shoot it
so we we shoot maybe one line from the
script and a bunch of girl gobbledygook
about shoes and gary goes
cut good let's move on
and i go well wait a minute what about
the
the other lines and he goes shoes are
good
and i look at richard and richard goes
that's what i'm talking about oh my god
we when we wrapped pretty woman we we
all had a great time but we thought this
will never see the light of day it's
there's no really there's no story
there's nothing here
and gary had it all we just couldn't see
the fires for the trees
you